donc chers collègues nous avons plaisir
d'accueillir messieurs jancovici et
grandjean leur qualité d'associé
fondateur du cabinet de conseil et
d'expertisé carbone 4 ce cabinet qui a
presque dix ans d'existence et
spécialiste incontestable des bilans
carbone ses deux cofondateurs là et
l'autre polytechnicien ont par leurs
interventions leur écrit un rôle
important d' animateur du débat sur la
transition énergétique
plus généralement sur la conciliation
d'écologie avec les activités
productives qui le coeur de notre
mission
leur approche des problèmes semblent
assez voisines des orientations de la
fondation nicolas hulot
même si bien évidemment carbone 4 est
une structure totalement indépendante
par exemple sur grange en a été
président du comité des experts du débat
national sur la transition énergétique
à ce titre ce titre de grands experts
nous avons souhaité les entendre et nos
interrogations dépasseront donc les
seuls spécialité du cabinet carbone 4
ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler désormais
la sphère volkswagen puis à présent les
difficultés d'autres constructeurs à
respecter des niveaux d'émissions qu'ils
annoncent pourtant sur certains
véhicules pose de sérieux problèmes
une perte de crédibilité risque ou a
déjà entaché la répète réputation de
tout un secteur
en tout cas ces événements perturbe
grandement les consommateurs à cet égard
le choix de la motorisation diesel est
devenu hasardeuses à bien des points de
vue
d'autant que le régime de taxation de ce
carburant est appelé à s'alourdir
nous aimerions obtenir de votre part une
analyse sur la validité des politiques
conduites jusqu'ici sur les pollutions
atmosphériques notamment en zone urbaine
sur ce point les enjeux de la mobilité
évidemment reste tout à fait déterminant
au delà des rejets de co2 comment et à
quel rythme revient-il de traiter les
questions relatives au nox
spécifiquement et aux particules fines
c'est à dire les problématiques au moins
aussi sensible mais dans le public ne
découvre les impacts que depuis peu et
dieu sait s'il ya des rebondissements
tous les jours dans un premier temps
nous vous proposons de vous entendre
pour un exposé limites
r suite auquel même la rapporteure
delphine batho vous posera une première
série de questions et éventuellement nos
collègues s'ils arrivent pourront lui
emboîter le pas merci
pardon pendant classés
sauvé en route donc bonjour à toutes et
à tous je vais vous passer quelque chose
qui est du travail de feignants c'est à
dire que je vais recycler un quelques un
diaporama que j'ai largement utilisés
pour dans le cadre d'une audition pour
une audition une intervention pour une
association qui s'appelle avenir
transport qui sévit dans ses murs enfin
juste à côté et je vais essayer de
partir alors je vais faire un peu de
stratosphère et alain va faire des
choses plus pragmatique c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est articulée dans le pour
aujourd'hui et la stratosphère va viser
notamment à replacer la problématique
des transports dans la problématique
générale énergie climat
dit autrement est ce que c'est un sujet
plus important que les autres moins
important que les autres est-ce que
c'est qu'il va se passer plus tard ne
dépend que de notre bon vouloir ou bien
il ya un certain nombre de contraintes
externes qui sont déjà à l'oeuvre et qui
vont s'appliquer que ça nous plaise ou
pas et donc je vais commencer par donc
un cadrage un peu macroscopique ce tueur
de quoi est fait l'avenir et pour vous
réveiller tout de suite j'ai par exemple
expliqué qu'à partir de maintenant je
crois fortement que la récession sera le
paysage structurelles donc si on pense à
des mesures qui sont très gourmandes en
capitaux et injuste on va pas les mettre
en oeuvre
je crois que le pétrole est déjà qu'on
va pas en france et donc même si les
gens ont envie d'en consommer plus banal
n aura pas plus
je crois que les raffineries ne sortent
pas 0% de diesel et qu'elle ne sortiront
pas 0% diesel donc si on dit qu'on veut
plus de diesel bas on a un petit sujet
avec 30% du pétrole utilisé sur terre
etc etc
voilà je vous donnais un certain nombre
de cadres cadrage de cette nature et
après la partie pas parce que c'est une
personnalité parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est arrangé cet après midi à la
rentrée au lycée bull donc plus
appropriée avant un échange
j'imagine voilà alors je vais commencer
par revenir aux grands succès
diplomatiques de décembre qui s'appelle
l'accord de paris l'accord de paris vous
en avez évidemment entendu parler je me
suis permis une petite taquineries en
guise de commentaire sur cet accord dans
une chronique récente dans les échos que
j'ai titré victoire de starter
c'est à peu près ce que je vais vous
expliquer maintenant vous avez une
droite qui est absolument capital
quand on cherche à relier les
conséquences environnementales futur à
nos actions d'aujourd'hui qui est ce
graphique d'apparence austère tirées
d'un rapport du giec que je vous
présente maintenant ce graphique il dit
une chose si vous regardez et lacs ce
duo
vous avez une graduation qui concerne
les émissions que les hommes feront
entre 1850 et 2100 donc c'est des
milliers de milliards de tonnes de co2
encore et si vous êtes à cet endroit
sont là que ça veut dire que vous avez
émis mille milliards de tonnes de co2
entre 1850 et 2100 la 2000 à 3000 etc
il se trouve que à fin 2015 on en avait
émis à peu près 2000 qui viennent comme
vous pouvez le voir sur la décomposition
de droite du charbon on a un énorme
sujet dans le monde avec la production
électrique au charbon de la
déforestation du pétrole et du gaz vous
voyez tout de suite que le pétrole n'est
pas le seul sujet dans le changement
climatique donc quand dans les rues de
copenhague avait des tas d'associations
qui se baladait en dix ans le pétrole
tube climat il y contribue
mais il n'est pas le seul acteur dans
cette affaire si vous reportez donc les
émissions sur la droite qui est
matérialisée par l'ensemble de courts de
couleur là et que vous allez ensuite sur
l'axé vertical vous avez l'augmentation
de température pour laquelle on a déjà
signé en 2100 dit autrement aujourd'hui
l'inertie du système climatique et
notamment de son parti au ce et annick
et de son compartiment clio génique donc
les calottes polaires fait que nous
sommes absolument certains d'avoir 1,2
alors une barre d'incertitude plus ou
moins quelque chose
donc il se pourrait qu'on est déjà à
dire qu'on est déjà dépasser les 1,5
avec les émissions à date donc les
émissions à date interdites physiquement
qu'on soit en dessous de 1,5
c'est possible et il se peut si on a de
la chance que ça ne nous garantissent
que 0,7 ou 0,8
si je renverse le raisonnement je dis je
veux pas plus de deux degrés c'est
l'accord de paris à ce moment j'ai le
droit à trois mille milliards de tonnes
de co2 entre 1850 et 2100 et comme j'en
ai déjà émis 2001 petit raisonnement
budgétaire simple nous amène à la
conclusion qu'il en reste 1000 qu'on
peut émettre
donc si on sait rien sur les deux degrés
nous avons un objectif physique de base
qui consiste à ne pas émettre sur le
restant du 21e siècle plus de la moitié
de ce nous avons déjà émis jusqu'à
maintenant sur une période on était
entre un et sept milliards d'habitants
alors que sur le reste du siècle il
paraît qu'on va être entre 7 et 9 et où
un certain nombre de gens ne possédait
pas de voiture ou de billets d'avion à
prix cassés si je traduis ça en terme de
dynamique de réduction des émissions il
ya une chose absolument capital là aussi
à avoir en tête qui est que ça suppose
que les émissions mondiales soit / fois
d'ici à 2050 si je suis je fais de la
proportionnelle par rapport à maintenant
c'est là que les émissions là français
sont divisés par trois mais aussi que
les émissions des burkinabés sont
divisées par trois et si je suis un peu
plus communiste et que je dis qu'à
l'arrivée tout le monde a droit à la
même chose les émissions d'un français
sont à diviser par 5 comme les émissions
d'un français vous le verrez après ne
proviennent que très peu du secteur
électrique ça veut dire qu'il faut
essentiellement taper ailleurs tout à
l'heure vous demandez à un avis sur les
politiques publiques menées en france je
suis désolé de dire ça devant la
personne qui était en charge au moment
du tnt eux mais enfin c'est largement
tromper de problèmes en entrée du cnt au
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il est rien sorti
ça veut dire quand c'est largement
tromper de problèmes en entrée voilà
maintenant un camembert qui va vous
donner les émissions mondiales donc
rappelez vous voulez divisé par trois
d'ici à 2050
20% des émissions mondiales viennent des
centrales à charbon 21 très exactement
il faut savoir que le charbon est le
premier contributeur à la production
électrique dans le monde
et soit dit en passant sur les 14
dernières années la production tricot au
charbon dans le monde
à aubenas fois plus puisque la
production électrique au photovoltaïque
donc le vrai n'oubliez les communiqués
de presse et ce qui se raconte dans le
journal français le vrai fait marquant
de l'évolution de la production
électrique sur les 15 dernières années
c'est l'explosion du charbon la chine
c'est plus vrai maintenant mais il ya
encore quelques années mettait chaque
semaine en service l'équivalent d'un ne
permet au charbon chaque semaine
vous avez actuellement 1800 gigawatts de
centrales à charbon installés dans le
monde quand vous avez nos fameux 63
gigawatts qui nous turlupine temps de
nucléaire en france donc 1800 sur le
charbon après que vous avez 6 % des
émissions qui viennent de centrales
électriques au pétrole et au gaz donc la
production électrique à combustible
fossile fait 27% dans le monde tout de
suite vous allez comprendre une chose
c'est que tous les modes de propulsion
électrique
on devra toujours regarder d'où vient
l'électricité pour savoir si c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise affaire
non seulement en termes de co2 mais
également en termes de particules on a
récemment fait au sein du cabinet
carbone 4 une analyse qui montre que si
vous mettez un tramway est tout à fait
électrique dans un contexte dans lequel
il est alimentée au charbon
les émissions de particules les
émissions de particules de l'ensemble du
système sont à peu près les mêmes que si
vous avez des bus au diesel juste ne
sont pas émises au même endroit mais
vous avez à peu près les mêmes donc
simplement elles sont déportés dans la
production électrique 5 % des émissions
mondiales viennent des cimenteries bon
sens et pas trop à ce sujet aujourd'hui
10 % viennent du reste de l'industrie
dans l'acier fait encore 4 ou 5 % 6 %
viennent des chaudières de bâtiments en
direct 13 % viennent des transports oui
tout de suite dans le monde
les transports c'est un sujet mais c'est
pas un sujet plus importante les
centrales à charbon c'est pas un sujet
plus important que l'industrie
c'est un sujet parmi un certain nombre
est dense et 13% qui viennent des
transports 4 viennent des voitures dans
le monde 4 des camions trois des bateaux
et de des avions donc ses réparties sur
un certain nombre de modes 20% vient
d'agriculture on n'en parlera pas
aujourd'hui pour cent de la
déforestation n'en parlera pas
aujourd'hui on se sent bien d'autres
bricoles donc vous voyez que dans le
monde les transports c'est 13% tout à
effet de serre confondues donc
s'attaquer aux transports c'est
indispensable s'attaquer transports
c'est pas suffisant
si je regarde maintenant l'europe
l'europe les transports occupe une part
plus importante parce que d'autres
secteur occupe une part moins importante
donc les transports ces 20% après vous
retrouvez le reste
et si maintenant vous regardez au sein
des transports
d'où viennent les émissions vous avez le
transport routier qui en fait à peu près
les trois quarts on va dire et là dedans
selon l'endroit où vous mettez les
utilitaires parce que les utilitaires
font l'objet d'un long débat
statistiques pour savoir si c'est dans
le fret la canette du plombier vous
savez est ce que la cagnotte du plombier
transporte avant tout le matériel du
plombier ou avant tout le plombier si
c'est avant tout le plombier ça va dans
les transports de personnes si c'est
avant tout la camier la trousse à outils
du plombier ça va dans le fret et c'est
pas rien les utilitaires parce que les
utilitaires ça fait 20 % en gros de la
consommation de carburant dans le pays
donc on n'est pas en train de parler
d'un truc marina mais bref vous avez
fret et marchandises et après vous voyez
la marine marchande et l'aviation qui
représente des choses plus plus
secondaires alors maintenant je vais
vous poser un premier élément de décor
extrêmement important à avoir en tête
l'europe est déjà en contrainte en ce
qui concerne son approvisionnement
pétrolier l'approvisionnement pétrolier
européen est en décrue subi et j'insiste
sur pour le subit depuis 2006 en 2006
c'est pas le grenelle de l'environnement
ce teknival à mme royal ni monsieur
borloo s'est pas plus les runes m vous
allez voir que en fait c'est la géologie
qui s'en est chargé vous avez ici un
graphique qui vous donne la
décomposition de ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler la production de pétrole dans
le monde depuis 1900 alors pourquoi je
vous dis coutume d'appeler parce qu'en
fait les statisticiens dans l'univers
des combustibles liquides publie des
chiffres qui agrège des choses qui sont
du pétrole et des choses qui n'en sont
pas tout ça est temps dans une catégorie
qui s'appelle des liquides alors qu'est
ce qu'on va trouver là dedans on va
trouver je suis désolé c'est en anglais
parce que je suis un feignant donc j'ai
fait ce truc en anglais vous allez
trouver une première catégorie tout en
bas qui sont ceux qu'on a coutume
d'appeler des extra lourd donc les extra
lourd c'est les sables bitumineux du
canada typiquement l'orénoque dans l'est
du venezuela etc et ça part et ça ça
vous fait vraiment des carburants quand
ça passe dans les installations qui sont
sur site au dessus vous allez trouver le
vrai pétrole or le vrai pétrole cru delà
pétrole brut c'est ce qui sort vraiment
sous forme de pétrole dont vous faites
un trou dans un gisement de pétrole et
il en sort vraiment du pétrole est au
dessus vous avez deux produits à la fois
condensat et ngl qui ne sont pas du
pétrole mais qui sont dans les
statistiques de production de bp compter
avec le pétrole
si vous regardez tout ce qui est contée
avec le pétrole vous voyez que ça
augmente sans discontinuer moins vite
qu'avant mais certes depuis les chocs
pétroliers
si vous retrancher les liquides de gaz
en liquide de gazon c'est quoi ces et
anne propane/butane c'est ce que vous
utilisez pour partir en camping c'est
absolument pas du pétrole ça peut faire
un peu de carburant sous forme de gpl
mais ça n'est pas du pétrole et le
condensat c'est des molécules un peu
plus lourde qui sortent aussi avec le
gazar comme l'adduction de gaz est en
croissance liquides de gaz et condensats
augmente par contre vous voyez que la
production de pétrole stricto sensu
c'est à dire le la somme du rouge sombre
et du rouge moins sombre n'augmente plus
depuis 2005
en 2005 il s'est passé un fait
déclencheur de la crise économique
actuelle qui est que la production de
pétrole dans le monde a cessé
d'augmenter de là un enchaînement les
prix de l'immobilier se sont retournés
aux états unis en 2006 et ouest à sud
chili donc c'est pas la crise financière
qui a provoqué la crise économique c'est
un ralentissement industriel sensible
dans tous les pays de l' ocde qui a
déclenché la crise économique qui a
déclenché la crise financière c'est bien
dans ce sens là que ça s'est passé
soit dit en passant les mêmes causes
vont produire les mêmes effets le bas du
pétrole en ce moment va contraindre
l'offre à la baisse parce qu'un salon du
projet sont pas rentables et
réinvestissements arrête d'être fait la
production va cesser de croire que des
croix dans un certain nombre de zones
c'est déjà le cas aux états unis
du coup le pib va être encore plus
contraints qu'avant et on va avoir de
nouveau à mon avis un coup de tabac
financiers dans n'importe quoi entre six
mois et deux ans et demi c'est dans ce
cadre là qu'il faut penser des
politiques publiques je le dis pas juste
pour me faire plaisir ou vapeur c'est
dans ce cadre là qu'il faut penser les
politiques publiques dit autrement
penser les politiques publiques
aujourd'hui en pensant qu'ils auraient
plus en plus d'argent pour financer des
trucs sympathiques malheureusement c'est
plus vrai il y en aura de moins en moins
globalement m deuxième chose qui est
intéressant d'avoir en tête vous avez
ici la décomposition par nature de
produits raffinés des raffineries dans
le monde donc le pétrole on utilise pas
brutal mais dans une raffinerie il en
sort des produits raffinés ce que vous
voyez c'est que depuis 1965
la part des produits légers alors qu'est
ce qu'on met dans les produits légers
c'est gpl nafta qui est le produit
utilisé pétrochimie et les sens c'est
flat aux alentours de 30%
au dessus vous avez fuel et diesel et
j'ai oublié de le mentionner kérosène
donc le jet fuel et vous voyez que c'est
légèrement croissant mais pas tellement
augmente pas tout petit peu et donc sur
les diesels de ces mêmes produits
pétroliers et la première enseignements
pour la mission si on dit le diesel on
n'en veut plus il va continuer à sortir
des raffineries
donc vous faites un grand trou quelque
part et vous mettez dedans puisque je
vois pas trop ce que vous allez faire
d'autre le parc mondial de raffineries
on va pas comme ça change et les coupes
de raffineries les coupes de raffinerie
ça se change pas sa raffinerie et des
installations de distillation c'est le
truc extrêmement capitalistique une
raffinerie ça vaut quelques milliards
d'euros pièce on n'arrive pas comme ça
overnight en disant voilà ça me plaît
plus j'ai pas envie de diesel joue à
autre chose mais ça reste comme ça et
vous voyez au dessus des produits lourds
qui sont à la fois le fioul lourd qui
sert surtout dans la marine marchande et
un peu dans l'industrie et bitumes et du
brillant qui occupent à nouveau un tiers
plus ou moins un cochon donc il faut
bien voir que le carburant qui vous
intéresse aujourd'hui représentent un
tiers du pétrole produit dans le monde
un tiers
à partir du moment où le pétrole est
déjà en décrue d'approvisionnement dire
qu'on va se passer de ce tir là est
possible physiquement ça ne pose aucun
problème
par contre il faut voir que la
contrepartie en termes de contraintes
immédiates sur la mobilité
elle est réelle parce que ça ne sera pas
remplacé par autre chose rapidement
autre point que je veux développer
devant vous alors je vous ai dit
l'europe est déjà en dea en
approvisionnement pétrolier contraint la
baisse je vous montrerai la cour d'appel
j'aime bien raconter n'importe quoi si
c'était contre 1 à la baisse ça devrait
devenir très chères
et bien la réponse à cette question
légitime c'est que malheureusement ça
marche pas comme ça car il n'y a pas
alors ça c'est un autre truc très
désagréable à entendre
il n'ya pas d'élasticité long terme
entre prix et volumes sur le pétrole
dit autrement tout ce qu'on a pu
apprendre en cours d'économie sur le
fait que s'il y en a moins c'est plus
facile en a plus et moins cher ça marche
à court terme
donc si à très court terme vous diminuer
rapidement l'offre pétrolière
suffisamment les prix remonte mais ça
dure six mois un an un an et demi le
temps de casser la g économique et après
il se passe n'importe quoi
donc il n'existe pas d'élasticité long
terme prix volume et je veux bien parier
une bouteille de champagne avec
n'importe qui dans cette pièce que je
n'ai jamais dit nulle part qu'un pétrole
contre 1 allait devenir de plus en plus
cher à venir indéfinie et je n'ai pas
dis parce que je le pense pas vous avez
ici donc un graphique sur lequel j'ai
reporté s'est récemment plaint les
données sont publiques j'ai reporté en
abscisse la quantité de pétrole consommé
dans le monde et en ordonnée le prix du
baril en monnaie constante
si le pétrole devait devenir plus cher
quand il y en a - et bien tous les
points devrait être le long d'une espèce
de courbe décroissante comme ça moi y en
a plus c'est cher plus il y en a moins
c'est cher
d'accord il devrait être le long d'une
courbe comme ça les fameuses cours vous
savez décroissante que vous avez vues
sur les modélisations économique en vous
voyez tout sauf ça en vous devez
théorisé le prix du pétrole
on pourrait presque de manière
caricaturale dire qu'il ya que deux
régimes stables
il ya un régime dans lequel le volume
fait n'importe quoi avec un prix
constant
puis un régime dans lequel le pli fait
n'importe quoi avec un volume constant
puis un régime dans lequel plume fait à
nouveau n'importe quoi avec un prix
quasi constant puis de nouveau un régime
dans lequel le volume est constant et le
prix fait n'importe quoi donc
ne croyez pas une seconde que un
approvisionnement pétroliers contre un
se répercute sur un prix perpétuellement
croissant c'est pas ça qui se passe la
manière dont le système s'organise on
n'aura pas le temps de développer
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas c'est la
conclusion à laquelle je suis arrivé et
ça a très bien marché à la fois en 2007
et en 2011 je pense que malheureusement
ça va marcher maintenant c'est qu'un
approvisionnement contraint à la baisse
vous fait une récession ça j'en suis
absolument certain mais ça vous fait pas
nécessairement un prix qui fait
n'importe quoi qui est structurellement
croissant
il est croissant transitoirement ça oui
après je sais pas et par ailleurs il
faut retenir une chose importante
alain et moi avons commis un ouvrage on
s'est fiancée à se marier et nos
fiançailles ont pris la forme d'un
ouvrage s'appelait le plein s'il vous
plaît dont je me rappelle très bien que
mon éditeur de l'époque
enfin autre éditeur de l'époque avait
fait faire un livre par députés présents
à l'assemblée y en a près le serbe a un
qui sont encore là aujourd'hui je suis
pas si vous l'avez lu
je probablement non je le regrette dans
lequel on expliqué que la taxe carbone
était le meilleur impôts qu'ils soient
et c'était entre autres choses et c'est
sur la base de cet argument soit dit en
passant que j'ai convaincu
l'éditorialiste le plus libéral des
échos d'y adhérer
c'est un moyen de conserver la rendent
chez soi il faut bien voir que si les
carburants ne sont pas taxés à chaque
hausse du prix de marché c'est le
producteur qu'encaisse la rente
si vous taxez le carburant chez vous
c'est vous qui gardait la rente
il ya donc quelque chose que j'ai
coutume de dire c'est on peut dire ce
qu'on veut sur les fonctionnaires
français qui sont une bande d'incapables
enfin à tout prendre je préfère financer
les phanères incapable de chez moi que
les financer l'école et fonctionnaires
incapable d autres donc il faut bien
comprendre que la taxe carbone protège
le consommateur elle ne le ne saigne pas
le protège comme c'est une prime
d'assurance
la taxe carbone et c'est obligatoire de
payer les assurances si on n'a jamais
dit que payer les instances de manière
obligatoire était diminuée le pouvoir
d'achat d'une manière scandaleuse et je
regrette amèrement que la baisse
actuelle du pétrole on n'en ai pas
profité pour dire on va se partager la
baisse
j'avais un argument c'est typiquement
tellement simple soit on va pas vous
saignez on va se partager la baisse et
crack
on monte la fiscalité sur le carbone
voilà ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose pour lequel nos enfants ne nous
diront pas merci
donc je reviens à mon histoire de
pétrole la meilleure démonstration que
le prix est pas prévisible ce que tout
ce qui s'écrit s'essayent à des
prévisions de prix raconte n'importe
quoi
vous avez ici une le prix du pétrole
tels qu'il a vraiment été en monnaie
constante c'est la courbe bleue que vous
avez sur ce graphique donc la courbe
bleue que vous voyez là et tous les
traits de couleurs autres sont les
projections de prix à date fait par l'
agence internationale de l'énergie entre
2003 et 2014
bon si on a chez carbone 4 un ingénieur
s'amuse à nous faire des simulations de
cette nature ou un directeur du
marketing qui s'amusent à nous faire des
prévisions de ventes de cette nature je
peux vous assurer qu'il restera pas
longtemps
l'eeie continue à faire tous les ans des
projections de prix religieusement
reprise par le monde
j'ai envoyé aux journalistes du monde
repris ce truc là ce graphique en lui
disant une projection prix de l'agneau
est un non-événement absolue je pense
que vous devriez faire un papier sur le
fait que c'est un non-événement absolue
assure qu'il n'a pas fait le papier par
contre on continue à entendre ici et là
que les yeux prévoit que le prix du
baril se rabat pendant cinq ans il ans à
[ __ ] rien moi non plus du reste dans
un flou trop rien il sera ce qu'il sera
je peux même vous dire une chose si le
prix du baril reste durablement bas sur
les cinq ans qui viennent c'est que la
récession sera particulièrement sauvage
c'est la seule chose que je suis capable
de vous dire voilà la seule projection
prix intelligente que j'ai vu ces
dernières années
c'est le fmi qui l'a fait et le fmi vous
dix à douze mois je ne sais pas ce
qu'est le prix du pétrole
voilà ça c'est une projection prix
intelligente on connaît la personne qui
a fait cette projection de prix soit dit
en passant enfin qui a fait ce genre de
graphie on connais bien maintenant et à
la banque d'angleterre
c'est ce genre de choses qu'il faut
avoir en tête
par contre le pétrole conditionne
l'économie c'est ce que je voulais vous
dire vous avez ici alors ça c'est pas la
preuve
mais c'est la conséquence logique du
raisonnement vous avez ici un graphe
fixe auquel j'ai reporté en rouge
la variation de la production mondiale
de pétrole en volume donc c'est le
nombre de barils qui sont produits et en
bleu vous êtes la variation du pib par
personne en moyenne mondiale
il ya le meilleur indicateur avancé que
vous ayez aujourd'hui et c'est un
indicateur avancé jean simmons et un
petit décalage de pétrole précède le pib
c'est la variation de pétrole dans le
monde
donc je vous le redis bas prix du
pétrole le celle là il commence à
décroître les tar sands tous les projets
sont remis sur étagère les
investissements de hand stories dans les
gisements matures sont remis sur étagère
donc la production va se passer donc le
pib va se tasser
or vous allez voir après la tête de
l'endettement et six ou sept dernières
années donc il va se passer quelque
chose
je ne sais pas où quand comment mais les
choses je mon seul souhait c'est que ça
se passe
avant 2017 enfin avant mai 2010 est
parce que sinon encore pour élire
quelqu'un qui va faire des promesses
fantaisistes et on aura la gueule de
bois rapidement derrière voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire sur
l'approvisionnement européen en pétrole
vous avez ici la décomposition de
où j'ai oublié de vous dire alain et moi
on fait souvent un goût
good cop bad cop donc vous avez compris
à qui vous avez affaire en premier vous
avez ici
l'approvisionnement européen en pétrole
depuis 1965 lorsque vous voyez c'est que
avant les chocs pétroliers ça venait
pour l'essentiel des importations
puis après les chocs pétroliers la mer
du nord s'est développée est passé par
un maximum en 2000 donc le pic pétrolier
ça existe je les rencontre et malgré la
hausse du prix du baril parce qu'en 2006
le prix est remonté très fort donc là je
peux vous dire que les investissements
ils sont allés à fond
ils produisent un peu maintenant là vous
voyez le déclin s'est un peu tassé
m'enfin bon il va continuer et vous avez
les importations en verre et vous voyez
qu au moment où la production mondiale
de pétrole atteint un plateau
les importations se veut arrête
déclinante elles sont contraintes à la
baisse parce que dans une marmite dont
la taille n'augmente plus le fait que
les émergents et les consommateurs des
pays producteurs se servent de plus en
plus ça en laisse de moins en moins sur
le marché international pour les
importateurs historique
nous avons perdu depuis 2006 et ça n'est
pas le fruit d'une politique publique 20
% quasiment du pétrole disponible en
europe
d'où la raison pour laquelle depuis 2007
la production industrielle décline dans
tous les pays européens sauf l'allemagne
et c'est pas le fait que montebourg est
un abruti c'est juste le fait que de
moins en moins de pétrole fait qu'on a
de moins en moins de camions qui
circulent s'agrippe un peu la machine
industrielle et on produit de moins en
moins et ça va continuer et ça va
continuer ceux-ci allons avec cela vous
avez ici la variation du pib européen
depuis 50 ans vous voyez ça c'est les
trente glorieuses
quand mes parents ont acheté leur maison
pour trois fois rien après on a eu les
chocs pétroliers
donc la moyenne de la croissance du pib
pendant les trente glorieuses 5%
la moyenne pour pendant les trente ans
qui ont suivi le choc pétrolier jusqu'en
2007 2% et la moyenne depuis le choc de
2007 2008 sert depuis que la production
de pétrole mondial s'arrête de croître
dire où et quand vous regardez la
tendance sur son taux de croissance
je ne suis pas sûr que je parierais mon
dernier euros d'économies sur le fait
que ça va repartir à la hausse
et tout ça dans un contexte de dette qui
a augmenté alors on l'a aussi on
vilipende les argentiers français qui
sont non respectueux des deniers publics
vous voyez qu'à partir de 2007 ici là
vous avez un boost dans l'accroissement
de l'endettement mais enfin vous avez
exactement la même chose en grande
bretagne et même en bien pire puisque
c'est 40 % à 90 % du pib sur la dette
publique et les etats unis champions
toutes catégories ont doublé leur dette
publique entre 2007 et 2013 et je vais
finir là-dessus avant les chocs
pétroliers dans tous les pays dotés d
aulas joue le monde pour les états unis
mais c'est vrai pour tp pile ocde
le rythme de croissance de l'énergie
vous donner le rythme de croissance de
la production industrielle qui vous
donnait le rythme de croissance du pib
si je prends l'énergie en rouge le pays
bété embrun le p pardon la production
industrielle embrun le pib en bleu et
l'endettement fédéral envers vous voyez
que bleu brun et rouge sont
indiscernables
il se recouvre totalement avant les
chocs pétroliers dit autrement vous avez
plus d'énergie vous avez plus de
production industrielle vous avez plus
de pib après les chocs pétroliers vous
voyez que l'énergie se met à croître
moins vite et en apparence ont des
matérialistes qui est une excellente
affaire sauf que la dématérialisation va
de pair avec une croissance de la dette
et là aussi j'ai une conviction je
n'aurai pas le temps de développer
aujourd'hui qui est que une partie de
cette dématérialisation elle est
indissociable d'une croissance de la
dette parce que c'est de l'inflation
d'actifs donc quand il ya une crise
financière ça se corrige dans l'autre
sens une fois je vous ai dit ça quelques
un cadrage là aussi macro que j'ai en
tête sur la manière d'envisager l'avenir
de n'importe quoi y compris le diesel
dans les transports la règle qui va
devenir cardinal maintenant si on veut
avoir des plans qui se réalise
j'insiste qui se réalise c'est qu'il va
falloir faire mieux avec moins
et c'est pas juste dans les transports
c'est d'une manière générale faire mieux
avec moi toutes les projections de
trafic qui base soit la construction
d'infrastructures soient les
substitutions de parc soit et cetera
doivent s'envisager avec des trafics
stable ou décroissant
c'est pas absolument certain que ce sera
comme ça tous les ans par contre c'est
absolument certain que c'est la règle de
prudence
si ça passe dans ce contexte là on est
sûr que ça passe si ça va mieux
par contre si on compte sur le fait que
ça aille mieux pour que ça passe ça
marchera pas dernier point vous avez
constaté que les taux longs étaient
devenus nuls
l'avenir nous intéresse un peu donc là
aussi dans tous les calculs et bilan
socio-économique c'est un truc et nous
amuse beaucoup et moi j'ai un avis qu il
faut qu on actualise avec un taux nul et
vous verrez que ça change un tout petit
peu l'ordre de mérite des choses qu'on
peut faire quelque chose qui est
absolument centrale c'est que la
technologie ne réglera pas tout on est
très technocentre et dans le monde
industriel ou environnemental sur le
fait qu'il suffit d'avoir la bonne
techno et piquera qu'on va régler le
problème dans un monde
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
histoire déjà c'est faux en général la
technologie a rajouté des usages les uns
sur les autres beaucoup plus qu'elle n'a
réglé des problèmes de manière globale
et donc il faut prononcer des gros mots
les gros mots s'appelle fiscalité les
gros mots s'appelle réglementation les
gros mots peuvent s'appeler obligations
ou interdictions dans cet excellent
livre que j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure
on a rappelé le plein s'il vous plaît on
a rappelé que la subvention ville à
l'est de l'état alors que la fiscalité
les remplit il serait bon de ne pas
l'oublier à un moment où comme je le
disais tout à l'heure le pib
n'augmentera plus et plus on s'endette
plus on dit aux gens pour leur assurance
vie ne vaudra plus rien parce que c'est
bien ça qu'il faut comprendre dans un
monde entre inflation l'apurement de la
dette c'est le défaut est le défaut
c'est que vous prenez votre assurance
vie si vous en avez plein jour on vous
dit mon bon monsieur ma brave dame une
bonne nouvelle pour vous ça valait
quelque chose ça vous aide voilà ça
c'est un défaut obligataire sur la dette
souveraine et ça finira par arriver
je ne sais pas vous dire quand je ne
sais pas vous dire comment je ne sais
pas vous dire ce sera grave ou pas mais
c'est évident que ça finira par arriver
et donc les ingénieurs que nous sommes
vous disent on est on adore bosser dans
le secteur dans lequel on bosse moi je
ne changerais pour rien au monde ne
comptez pas sur nous pour sauver le
monde de tout seul ça marchera pas
dernier point et c'est le chapitre 1 du
dernier bouquin que mon éditeur n'est
pas assez riche pour avoir envoyé à tous
les députés de cette assemblée
quand il sortir en poche peut-être de
l'arithmétique de base dans un monde
sans croissance
vous ne savez pas donner plus à gauche
sans donner moins adroite impossible si
vous dépensez cent par an et que un
budget augmente dans les cent par an les
autres diminue inexorablement le monde
en croissance dont nous sortons est un
monde facile parce que vous pouvez
régler les nouveaux problèmes sans vous
démunir des moyens qui ont servi à
régler les problèmes précédents dans un
autre sens croissance ça n'est plus
possible donc on va devoir faire des
choix on va devoir les partager avec la
population sinon on sera plus en
démocratie parce qu'on veuille venir on
va en sortir par est forte donc il va y
avoir un sujet de joie voilà je j'ai été
un peu appuyé sur tout ce cadrage parce
que c'était l'occasion pour moi de le
rappeler et c'est pas un cadrage qui
s'applique juste à la question de la
mission sur le diesel ça s'applique
aussi à la loi de finances ça s'applique
à tous les subventions sur les nerfs à
la rénovation à tout ce que vous voulez
on va vraiment devoir faire mieux avec
toi qu'est-ce qu'on peut essayer de
faire rentrer dans le cadre là
concernant les transports
alors c'est quelque chose encore une
fois qu'ils sont pas actionnable dans
les trois mois qui viennent c'est plus
un cadre de réflexion un peu large
un premier sujet et il restera des
voitures dans l'univers que nous avons
construit ça fait un siècle qu'on étale
les villes les gens vont pas déménager
en une semaine
donc il restera du transport individuel
et en particulier il faut savoir qu'en
france un tiers mobilité motorisée donc
en voiture c'est du déplacement domicile
travail
je peux vous assurer que le type qui est
content d'avoir trouvé un emploi de
magasinier à 30 bornes de chez lui vous
n'allez pas lui expliquer qu'il prend
pas ça va mal pour y aller nous et on
rit se trouve que quand j'ai fait le
premier bilan carbone d'une grande
surface en périphérie j'ai été
extrêmement impressionnés par la
distance moyenne que parcourait les gens
pour venir au travail
tant qu'on est dans un univers de joie
si les gens ont envie d'un truc plus
intéressant à 30 bornes de chez eux
vous leur direz pas 90 il va prendre un
truc qui t'emmerde à 5 km de chez toi
comme on est dans avec une type de
métier qui est de plus en plus
spécialisés
les gens ont des univers de choix qui
sont de son nom dépendant de la distance
aux domiciles étaient pendants de
l'adéquation entre les besoins et leur
formation
et ça ça plaide pour des déplacements
qui augmente c'est particulièrement vrai
pour les classes moyennes et les cadres
supérieurs
donc tout ça pour dire que je ne crois
pas que les déplacements en voiture
individuelle vont être divisé par deux
dans les dix ans qui viennent
dans un monde qui continue à être sauna
blement stable sur le plan social du
coup ce que je crois c'est qu'une des
choses qu'il faut faire de manière
absolument jantes indépendamment du type
de carburant utilisé mais du coup ça
veut dire que toutes les émissions de
tous les carburants concernées baissent
c'est diminuer très rapidement la
consommation unitaire des voitures la
physique étant ce qu'elle est je vous
rappelle que il ya là un domino mv2 donc
un physique étant ce qu'elle est vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça sans baisser la
masse et la puissance des véhicules en
circulation est aujourd'hui sans faire
de la pub pour personne le truc qui
passe à peu près la rampe c'est une deux
chevaux hybride est à l'air comprimé
donc typiquement ce que sait faire
peugeot ça ça vous fait du 2 litres au
cent sans trop de problème donc vous
faites des voitures qui font 500 kg qui
font 110 ou 120 kilomètres/heure de
vitesse de pointe qui ont un moteur de
30 chevaux et avec la technologie
moderne les airs de litres au cent sans
aucun problème mais il faut l'incitation
fiscale ou réglementaires pour que les
gens achètent ça et pas autre chose
donc il faut remettre en place la
vignettes ou quelque chose qui y
ressemble
un bonus malus annuel si vous voulez il
faut mettre en place n'a la casse mais
qui ont un delta très fort entre la
consommation de la voiture abandonnée et
la consommation de la voiture âgé il
faut qu'ils aient un écart qui soit
vraiment très conséquent et il ya un
sujet évidemment qui vous dépasse
largement qui est qu' il faut être
capable à nouveau de faire de la
politique industrielle intégrée
c'est-à-dire qu'au moment où le
constructeur va se lancer avec son
investissement à quelques vieillards qui
permet de faire les voitures à 2 litres
au cent fois qu'ils sont sur des membres
donc il va falloir lui protéger le
marché
là on a un vrai sujet dans la
construction européenne alors là aussi
c'est pas activable tout de suite on a
un sujet dans la construction européenne
qui est que on devrait plaider pour le
fait que quand on doit sauver le climat
ou sauvegardés l'approvisionnement
énergétique européen
on a le droit de faire des entorses à la
fameuse sacro sainte règle de la libre
concurrence qui en fait ne sert qu'à
mettre un épais rideau brouillard pour
tous les investissements de long terme
que du coup on fera pas donc la voiture
à 2 litres au cent il faut y aller le
plus vite possible le plus fort possible
c'est pas une solution en particulier
pour le diesel mais c'est aussi une
solution pour le diesel puisque si on
diminue toutes les consoles nom de tous
on utilise en particulier - diesel est
par ailleurs quand vous avez baissé
l'assiette des consommations les
substitutions sont beaucoup plus facile
une fois vous avez amené les voitures à
2 litres au sens c'est plus facile de
remplacer l'essence par du méthane de
l'électricité ou ce que vous voulez que
quand elles sont 1 6 litre vous avez
trois fois moins d'énergie à substituer
deuxième chose qu'il faut encourager
très largement
vous connaissez de l'exemple de madrid
madrid a mis en place un système de bus
péri urbains qui ont permis à
l'agglomération
le gran madrid un peu l'équivalent de
l'île de france on va dire d'avoir un
taux d'utilisation des transports en
commun dans les déplacements motorisés
qui est le meilleur d'europe meilleurs
d'europe
ils sont très loin devant les hollandais
et le fameux vélo d'amsterdam
si vous regardez non pas le centre-ville
d'amsterdam mais la conurbation urbaine
au sens large
cette affaire se place de la manière
suivante le bus à une boucle de
ramassage à 20 ou 30 km de là au delà du
périphérique
ensuite il fait un trajet d'une seule
traite jusqu'à la station de métro la
plus externe du métro madrilène
et là il ya une gare intermodale avec
les bus qui rentre au sous sol les gens
ils montrent un étage ils prennent le
métro ou lens ça dépend comment et
configurer les lieux et traquent les
genres pas sur un mode lourd on pourrait
faire ça en ile de france pour prendre
une région vous connaissez un peu
puisque vous y êtes au moins deux ou
trois jours par semaine
où on pourrait mettre des bus périurbain
tout autour de l'agglomération
parisienne avec des connexions au god
lourds et des aménagements évidemment
qui seraient nécessaires sur les gars de
erreurs ou les voilà donc ça c'est un
truc et ça c'est très très lourd que
c'est très peu lourd en capex un bus ça
coûte rien à part le but ça coûte rien
c'est quelque chose qui peut se mettre
en oeuvre extrêmement rapidement et ça
ça offre de la mobilité pour les
déplacements du quotidien très vite à
des gens qui aujourd'hui sont en train
d'être chassé de la mobilité en voiture
dernière juste un calcul qu'on a faits
au sein de carbone 4 que j'ai le droit
de vous donner puisque ils nous avaient
été payés par la sncf qui nous a donné
le droit de rendre ça public
les investissements du grand paris 40
milliards avant le facteur ppi sont ce
que vous savez que tous les prototypes
font l'objet de ce qu'on appelle le
facteur pis c'est à dire que vous partez
du budget initial vos x 3,14 et vous
avez ce qu'on a vraiment payé à la fin
ça marche pour eurotunnel sa marche pour
le p r d'olkiluoto ça marche pour
n'importe quoi et pour les gens qui sont
un peu dans notre métier pour n'importe
quel déploiement d'un logiciel un peu
compliqué et ça marche très bien aussi
donc le avant le facteur pis le grand
paris 40 milliards le transfert modal
qu'autorise ras le grand paris est à peu
près nulles j'insiste il est à peu près
nulle parce que ou bien vous faites des
infrastructures en ont déjà dense et à
ce moment il ya déjà une offre de
transport en commun et vous allez faire
du report entre transports en commun ou
de l'induction de trafic
sire que monsieur ou madame michu aura
le truc qui passe en bas de chez lui et
du coup il y aura un peu plus loin que
s'il était allé à pied ou bien vous
mettez la station de métro au milieu de
la pampa et si vous pouviez de la pampa
ya personne pour prendre le métro
alors vous allez me dire oui mais on va
construire plus tard oui sauf qu'au
moment où vous construisez prenant
plateau de saclay que je connais bien
parce que c'est pas très loin de chez
moi au moment où vous urbanisées ya pas
le métro donc les gens se mettent en
diffus à vingt ou trente bornes du
plateau de saclay je peux vous assurer
que le jour où le métro arrive qui fait
saclay paris les gens ils vont pas
déménager deux tours dans pour les
soumettre à paris n'en parlent et se
mettent à paris pour prendre le métro ou
se mettent à saclay ils vont rester à
tours bande donc vous avez un donc le
repos avec les mêmes 40 milliards vous
seriez capable
remplacer la totalité du parc automobile
francilien par des voitures à 2 litres
aux 100 en payant 80% de la facture pour
les âges et là vous économisez les deux
tiers du pétrole qu'on consomme donc il
faut être un peu agile dans ces
histoires là et ne pas se dire faut
faire les calculs et de pas se dire bon
y'a un truc évident j'interdis diesel là
pour apprendre et puis voilà qui les
problèmes entre aigle et non c'est tout
est imbriqué
un dernier point je vais en parler très
peu aujourd'hui il faut refaire des
transport longue distance en capital
mais il est passé la parole à alain
merci de votre attention
on va descendre un peu en niveau de
considération mais aussi la coller sur
le sur la mobilité donc ça fait deux
trois chiffres
il faut bien voir ça en tête puisque
l'arbitrage entre les particules qui
sont émis les nox et de co2 doit pas se
faire au détriment de l'objectif central
lucio de et réciproquement on doit pas
lutter contre le changement climatique
si c'est pour en poser les poumons de
tout le monde donc le secteur transport
est le deuxième secteur consommateurs
d'énergie et représentent 30% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est essentiellement lié à la
consommation de pétrole c'est pour ça
que jean m'a parlé énormément de pétrole
dans la préparation précédente
là c'est un chiffre qui permet
d'argumenter sur le fait que c'est très
sympa de penser qu'on va se passer de
voiture dans les années qui viennent
ça fait juste 25 ans qu'on est toujours
à 4 ap 3 83% des passagers kilomètres
qui sont en voiture c'est incroyablement
stable
donc ça veut pas dire que ça va pas
baisser mais et c'est quand même très
près ce toit y est même quand la
croissance des transports en milliards
de voyageurs kilomètres décidant sa
croissance un pâton souhait de la part
modale relative on vraiment pas beaucoup
bougé c'est aussi pour ça forcément
obligé de vous occuper de cela ça une
bad a été trouvée ou mais vous rappeler
qu au moment du grenelle de
l'environnement on avait des grands
espoirs
dans le report vers le fer etc on n'est
pas encore tout à fait bonnes nouvelles
et donc ça c'est important là on va
entrer dans les scénarios et dans les
projections des uns et des autres et je
vous parlais dans deux minutes des
travaux qui ont été faits l'ordre du
débat sur la transition énergétique
comment si critique et mettrait vraiment
très intéressant beaucoup d'informations
qui sont très utilisable
donc là là ça c'est pas dans le débat
c'est le passé vous voyez que mobilité
par personne se stabilise c'est quand
même une bonne nouvelle et c'est à ces
contrats fictifs parce que pareil si on
reprend les statistiques de la main de
tout à l'heure on pourrait croire qu on
avait une espèce d'idée il parle que le
pib croît avec la mobilité puis ensuite
la mobilité stagne avec un peu un pib
qui est stable décroissant en fait c'est
plus simple que ça c'est qu'on arrive
clairement une asymptote en termes de
demande de mobilité s'est pas
complètement lié à l'activité économique
a vraiment un moment où ça va encore on
a on a satisfait dans nos vérités donc
on n'en veut plus tant que ça la
deuxième bonne nouvelle mais avec une
petite contradiction c'est que vous
voyez en bleu la circulation des
voyageurs des voitures particulières là
c'est en base 100 en 1992 heures
précédemment c'était en giga voyageurs
kilomètres
c'est pour ça que c'est pas gai temps la
même tête mais ce que vous voyez en bleu
c'est le même phénomène que ce que vous
voyez dans la salle pressante ces quais
les voitures particulières ont une
circulation qui est stagnante depuis le
début des années 2000
et vous voyez que les émissions de gérer
ce commence à baisser
à peu près au même moment et tout ça est
quand même assez claire mounier p c'est
une graphie et pas démonstratif année
juste indicatif à l'afp vous faites la
consommation unitaire des voitures
particulières baisse sauf que il n'ya
par rapport entre ceux ci et sa place et
jusqu'à présent c'est quand même un peu
lié au fait qu'elle a parmi la part
relative du diesel s'est améliorée quand
même ça veut pas dire que c'est fatalité
et
il faut quand même avoir ça en tête si
on veut se projeter dans l'avenir alors
ça c'est le genre de petite équation
qu'on aime bien
même si ça a l'air un peu austère mais
en gros les quatre grandes variables de
deux logiques sur notre histoire de de
consommation et enrichir les transports
je rappelle juste un mot c'est que pour
atteindre nos objectifs en matière
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
faut aussi atteindre nos objectifs en
matière de baisse de la consommation
c'était un gros débat dans le denver je
m'en vais très bien certains pensaient
on croyait qu'il était possible de
baisser nos émissions de co2 sur
simplifier la consommation d'énergie et
en se disant baisser la consommation
d'énergie c'est décroissante 6 du fait
du raisonnement de jean-marc en fait ce
qui se passe et quand on se projette
dans l'avenir on est obligé de jouer sur
les deux variables on est obligé
considérer que pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre faut
aussi jouer sur la baisse de la
consommation d'énergie
donc cette consommation d'énergie finale
transports c'est donc j'ai dit 4 c 5 et
s'explique par cinq variables qui sont
là dedans en de mobilité en voyageur km
le mode parce que c'est du budget avion
ou la voiture particulière parce que
tous ces modes laon des consommations et
émissions de co2 très différentes
quelle est la motorisation parce qu'il a
aussi une voiture donc l électrique et
hybride again ou diesel n'a pas la même
consommation le taux de remplissage donc
ça je crois que c'est devenu très très
clair avec le succès de blaquart tout le
monde voit bien que si on arrive à
remplir mieux et ecublens on améliore
l'équation c'est aussi vrai aussi du bus
c'est pour ça que je remarque qu'on a
pas mal parlé tous les moyens qui permet
de mettre plus de personnes en relation
ou pour transporter de ferrailles sont
autant intéressant puis après c'est
l'efficacité énergétique du moteur sur
l'évolution des voyageurs kilomètres
donc la demande de mobilité vous voyez
donc il y avait quatre scénarios je suis
désolé c'est un tout petit peu trop
faible pahlisch il y avait quatre
familles de scénarios et les cas famille
de scénario elle était soit ondées
carbone par l'électricité donc cdec
donc c'est un cerveau très marqué dans
lequel on fait beaucoup de
l'électrification vous avez un autre
scénario qui est très marqué dans le
sens qui s'appelle sobre qui est un
scénario de
était inspiré de négawatt donc scénario
de très fortes
sobriété et efficacité et de scénarios
intermédiaires inquiets des quêtes un
scénario proche de l'ademe et d'yves qui
est un scénario intermédiaire avec une
diversité de secteurs technologiques
vous voyez que tous ces scénarios la de
raconter une histoire un peu distinctes
en matière de mobilité mais en gros la
tendance on voit quand même bien qu'on
reste sur une ligne de valve instable je
parierais pas beaucoup moins sur le
scénario bec dans cette affaire à celle
qui croit encore un peu de croissance je
pense qu'on est on peut raisonner
gentiment sur une hypothèse de stabilité
le deuxième grand sly que je vous montre
là je suis désolé mais je pense que j'ai
voulu commenter si vous le voyez quand
même c'était pour savoir si les uns et
les des choses différentes sur la part
modale des transports a notamment donc
celle qui est la plus importante c'est
le 4 1% dont on parlait tout à l'heure
ce que la part modale de la voiture
alors là on a des scénarios le scénario
dit est un scénario à 82% alors j'ai
oublié de dire ces quatre scénarios sais
quelle famille d'ici là il faut tout le
fameux facteur 4 c'est intéressant
elles permettent toutes ces failles très
content et de pensée de réflexion de
rêveurs qui permet de tous d'arriver à
une baisse très forte des émissions
c'est celle à ce qu'on voit c'est que il
ya un scénario le sénat au dif qui et
qui parie sur une stabilité la part
modale du delà de la voiture et deux
autres scénarios sobre et f qui
envisagent une baisse mais vous voyez
c'est quand même très intéressant de
regarder le type de chiffres qui manic
67 71 %
donc c'est des scénarios où la part
modale la voiture dans des séries assez
volontariste ne baisse que de 10% sur
quarante ans jusqu'à 2050
donc ça veut dire c'est très faibles
donc ça veut dire que dans votre mission
si vous devez faire des estimations à la
fois sur la la l'évolution la mobilité
dans l'avenir est à la fois sur la part
modale de la voiture mon maroc aux
fondations ce serait de parier quand
même sur des sur des sionistes hérésie
stabilité très très très très grande
j'insiste un peu parce que ces seigneurs
leurs intérêts
c'était qu'ils y étaient produits par
des équipes de chercheurs et des équipes
très hétérogène avec des visions du
monde très très contrastées c'était ça
le but du jeu c'est de voir est ce qu'il
ya des invariants en faisant travailler
des gens qui ont une vision du monde
quand même très différente celle là elle
est assez marrante aussi c'est les parts
de motorisation dans les véhicules
pilier donc vous voyez il ya des petits
il ya des petites icônes donc la prise
électrique
c'est la part de l'électricité vous avez
à me pompe avec une petite faim aussi la
part biocarburants vous avez une espèce
de truc qui ressemble à un éclair c'est
l'hybride rechargeable et vous avez les
carburant gazeux et là vous voyez aussi
assez bien plus fort que le cas
précédent vous voyez des visions du
monde un peu différente vous parie
beaucoup sur les carburants gaz au dec
évidemment paris beaucoup sur
l'électrification des voitures et les
autres sont sur des composants des mix
beaucoup plus complet moi ce que j'ai
retiré de cette affaire-là
c'est que bien douées et celui qui sait
quelle est la motorisation qui va
l'emporter en matière de voiture et je
serais à votre place je crois que
j'éviterai de mettre des quantités
colossales d'argent public sur un choix
technologique qui n'impose pas un
je crois que c'est ça un peu la
conclusion de sa autant la confusion du
sac précédent c'est-à-dire parier plutôt
sur un truc est très structurant et qui
est très
très acquis
parmi les experts qui travaillent là
dessus autant la conclusion de ce style
assez il ya manifestement une grosse
compétition possible entre différentes
technologies qui sont capables d'arriver
à des résultats performants en matière
de consommation
bon ça c'était les deux les deux
messages principaux que je voulais ce
que je veux attirer votre attention
concernant la demande de mobilité
là les quelques salles qui viennent sont
sur l'impact co2 du véhicule électrique
qui est une question qui est souvent
posée non donc on ne peut appeler ça
l'analyse de cycle de vie de la voiture
électrique donc enfin un peu la question
c'est au fait ce véhicule électrique est
ce qu'il faut indépendamment du point
précédent est ce qu'il faut parier
dessus et ce qu'il aura un effet très
positif en matière d'émissions des
effets tir parce que lui du coup en
centre ville
il répond à la question de
des particules fines et des docks ça
c'est vraiment complètement club donc on
pourrait se dire hors plaies quatre
pneus on est d'accord mais il ya encore
une grosse part les parcs à thème 2d qui
ont des véhicules on va ça le seul truc
qui répond vraiment bien ça c'est le
tramway ou là j'ai pas de pâques était
de nous sinon remarques tout à fait
important que j'aie qu'on a fait les ice
comparée du tramway et du bus en site
propre
un grand constructeur on a fait un truc
multicritères mais je là j'ai vraiment
pas le temps de s'en parler à ce stade
donc là ce que vous voyez dans dans
cette affaire là c'est que la voiture
électrique en france métropolitaine elle
est performante en grammes co2 par
kilomètre de manière relativement
indiscutable sur la durée de vie
de la voiture électrique je vais rentrer
un peu plus dans le détail
donc on est capable de faire une analyse
de cycle de vie complète donc c'est des
travaux qui ont été faits notamment par
l'ademe a deux qui sont donc bien fait
sur une durée 10 complète et donc un
usage à 150 mille kilomètres s'aperçoit
que le véhicule qu'il est électrique au
total sur sa durée de vie tout compris
la fabrication la mise à la casse il
concerne neuf tonnes de co2 équivalent
alors que le thermique il est à 22
donc on sent bien un truc c'est qu'il ya
un moment donné où les choses vont se
font se croit c'est parce que les
émissions liées à la fabrication sont
plus importantes pour la beauté de la
vallée de véhicules électriques que les
émissions d' usage donc la courbe
croiser à 25 qui 1000km d'utilisation
donc quand vous entendez un peu vite
l'idée qu'elle voiture électrique c'est
pas bien parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'émissions de co2 il ya beaucoup de jus
dans la fabrication c'est vrai mais il
faut jamais raisonné de manière simple
comme ça il faut aussi se dire par
ailleurs ce véhicule il roule enfin
mesure du fait qu'ils roulent pendant
lesquels m thil qui ne fait il émet
moins de co2 et consomme moins d'essence
pour appeler un chat un chat ou moins
d'une dizaine et donc il sera
rentabilisé son son son coût carbone
initiale à 25000 km j'insiste beaucoup
sur le fait que c'est une affaire
française c'est à dire qu'on a une
électricité
c'est pas une affaire de nucléaire c'est
une affaire de on a un mix électrique
bas carbone
donc j'imagine qu'on soit dans un pays
qui a beaucoup d'hydraulique
québec un vrai débat ça sera le même
résultat en norvège par exemple
en revanche si vous mettez de voitures
électriques en israël en chine
voir en allemagne et vous n'avez pas
étant les mêmes résultats parce que
l'électricité étant beaucoup plus
carbonée votre comparaison n'est pas du
tout la même c'est un sujet vraiment
important parce que si l'argument de
vente et le déploiement là on retombe un
peu ce qu'a dit jean marc sur un
déploiement d'une voiture trop bon sens
c'est que le marché atteignable et qui
est performant sur le plan du carbone
c'est le marché des pays qui ont un mix
électrique bas carbone
donc c'est pas complètement anecdotique
parce que je crois pas un instant que on
va et etam en vendre l'idée que la
voiture électrique c'est très bien dans
des pays dans l'électricité et aucun
vote voilà donc là je passe il ya un
dernier point sur le véhicule est écrit
sur lequel j'attire un peu votre
attention alors c'est d'une part deux
derniers points en fait le premier c'est
que contrairement à une idée toute faite
c'est pas parce qu'on mettra plein de
voitures électriques y aura besoin de
plein d'électricité
parce qu'en fait le rendre le moteur le
rendement du moteur électrique qui est
assez efficace
n'est ce pas jean marc et du coup quand
on fait un million de bagnols en
véhicules électriques ou hybrides
rechargeables ça consomme pas tant que
ça à 1,4 térawattheures c'est c'est un
petit bout de peur c'est la quadrette
millions de tueur donc attention
ouais un quart de faire ses six
réacteurs ceci 7/4 amateurs parent donc
donc on ne peut pas parié un genre
souvent j'entends ça le fait qu'on va
pouvoir consommer énormément
d'électricité grâce à un transfert des
voitures à motorisation diesel ou
essence sur l'abeille électrique ça me
paraît un peu osée en revanche chien
c'est un vrai sujet sur lequel il faut
être très attentif
c'est l'appel de puissance certes on en
a tous envie en tant que consommateur de
pouvoir recharger un futur crack et là
il faut derrière
la puissance installée sinon on risque
d'avoir de mauvaises surprises donc je
veux dire que là il ya un vrai sujet de
tunis un peu fort sur la gestion du
réseau
dernier point de ma présentation je vais
aller maintenant
deux choses qui sont les mesures que
auquel je pense s'il me mets à votre
place la première a déjà été dit par
jean-marc c'est une vraiment le moment
je ne dis pas que c'est le moment
politique mais excellent moment de faire
monter la taxe carbone une baisse de bar
in de 100 $ 50 $ baisse du prix du baril
de cinq ans de 5 200 $ à 50 dollars donc
ça vient de 50 de la celica stricte
d'une taxe carbone de 100 euros la tonne
de co2 faut bien voir ça en tête
c'est soit on a très peur avec des airs
aux attentes ce qui va dans tous les
sens oui à 100 euros la tonne de co2
c'est un peu environ 30 centimes d'euros
le litre est donc qu'en dit quand
jean-marc disais tout à l'heure
ce serait quand même bien de se partager
la baisse mais oui partagent un goût la
baisse chacun d'entre nous les
consommateurs ont profité d'une baisse
historique si on n'arrive pas à faire
remonter
la taxe carbone maintenant je sais pas
bien quand est ce qu'on va y arriver or
redisons erreur ou disons héros dire
encore que cet instrument est l'un des
meilleurs pour déplacer l'offre de
voitures c'est bien grâce à la tille ftp
pélata icpe que les constructeurs ont en
europe globalement produit des voitures
qui sont moins consommatrices que
s'étaient produites aux états unis donc
c'est vraiment un sujet clips et de la
faire maintenant je rentre dans des
petites mesures dont certaines vont vous
faire marrer et d'autres moi je pense
baisser la vitesse limite sur les routes
et des autoroutes me paraît déjà évoquée
par jean marc
mais me paraît une très bonne incitation
et même une incitation magistrale pour
que nos constructeurs fassent des
voitures qui consomment moins et qui
seront plus légères donc je parle de la
physique de l'évolution de l'offre de
voitures qui est celle qui consiste à
faire des voitures basse consommation
les fameuses de litres aux cent
forcément il faudra qu'elle soit un peu
plus légère
alors forcément des problèmes de
sécurité et donc 6
vous faites rouler les voitures plus
légères c'est en très dangereux si elle
roule vraiment vite ou si elle roule
enfin deux voitures un peu lourde qui
sont un peu rapide
on les raisons de physique raconter tout
à l'heure l'énergie cinétique et
proportionnées aux cadres la vitesse
accélérée le rajeunissement du parc de
voitures particulières dans les
conditions que jean-marc a rappelé tout
à l'heure je pense que le meilleur outil
ça reste la vigne et de co2 annuelles
dont on apprend à parler d il ya déjà
quelques années mais qui avait été
adoptée à l'époque voilà aider la
conversion des véhicules utilitaires
moi j'ai l'impression
on s'occupe pas assez des véhicules et
des utilitaires c'est donc jean marc a
rappelé l'importance tout à l'heure et
je pense que les voitures électriques
ont un marché de base et de référence
qui était le centre ville en plus ça
tombe bien puisque c'est votre sujet
central quand même les problèmes
d'asthme et d'essayer plutôt à la ville
et c'est là quand même qu'ils haussent
leurs grosses applications même si
d'après du social ça peut se discuter un
petit peu parce que ces souris une
deuxième voiture
je pense qu'il faudra pas oublier le
volet vélo électrique
vous savez sans doute que la grosse
difficulté du vélo électrique c'est le
risque d'accident la sncf nous l'a dit
et redit qu on a échangé avec eux donc
là si on fait des sondages d'opinion sur
le vélo électrique en centre-ville c'est
pas là c'est pas la pluie moi j'aime pas
me déplacer en vélo sur prend une douche
mais je suis pas du tout représentatif
du citoyen de base le problème principal
c'est la secure donc si on veut
développer le vélo électrique en
centre-ville il faut organiser la
sécurité
donc il ya il ya notamment des pistes
skiables n'y a pas d'autre là je suis
pas entré dans le détail je pense qu'il
faut penser aussi à l'aspect de roues
alors j'ai pas entendu tout de trouver
le shisha citoyens martèle chiffres en
tête mais la part du deux roues dans la
mobilité intra urbaine du deux roues
motorisé elle est très importante et
croissante alors je suis désolé on vous
donne réussi à la terre si vous les avez
pas mais c'est quand même pas des
gothiques parce que les deux roues
motorisés à ma connaissance sont très
émetteurs à la fois de particules fines
et et c'est assez peu connu c'est pour
ça que c'est un sujet d'intérêt il faut
il faut regarder ce point là parce que
c'est une action modeste mais qui a un
effet réel le bus biogen et viennent
vers le but rapide de la marque en
apparaît donc je reviens pas là dessus
en gros dans la substitution fallu zahaf
possible du gaz place de l'essence et du
diesel les deux secteurs les deux
segments qui sont intéressants à
regarder
c'est le bus et les camions je pense que
sur les voitures vous aurez un peu de
mal à faire pénétrer ça il ya des
voitures qui roulent bien sûr au gaz
il ya un plan de l'italie en afrique du
sud mais je pense qu'en france ça va
être un tout petit peu compliqué et puis
de toute façon vous allez avoir un
arbitrage à faire donc si je reprends ce
foisonnement en capex de jean-marc dans
les deux cas il ya un problème de
disponibilité des ponts et
d'infrastructures et donc faudra quand
même faire des choix et donc du coup je
pense que il ya un intérêt à garder tout
ce qui est bus parce que ses défauts de
captiver donc c'est relativement plus
simple à organiser en terme de deux
pompes et autres petits mécanismes
la présentation est plus facile donc
j'ai parlé du cervia mais je crois que
c'est peut-être pas la peine d'en parler
ici avec quand même
il faut il faut quand même se dire que
ça vaut le coup de regarder ses pieds
sur la sur les axes où il est légitime
et efficace et dernier point sur les
transports de marchandises parce qu'on a
quand même centre et toute notre
présentation sur la mobilité des
personnes
parce que c'est quand même le sujet
central de votre mission et j'imagine je
pense que comme je les dis sur le but
mettre du gaz dans lesquelles doit pas
il vient et km faut donc travailler la
logistique du dernier kilomètre il y en
a maintenant d'ailleurs ça se fait de
plus en plus vous savez que les grands
monoprix carrefour et autres commencent
vraiment à sanaa c'est à s'équiper en
flotte je pense que ça c'est que ce qui
devrait se faire assez bien comme par
ailleurs vous savez aussi que le biogaz
se développe gentiment même si c'est un
tout petit peu compliqué je pense que
c'est un axe sur les dix ans sur lequel
on peut parier études et les autorités
écrite en a pas parlé jean-marc là c'est
vraiment il m'a laissé ça quand même
donc étudié étudier les autres otages
donc si on est en train de faire ça
consiste à dire au fait les camions sur
les autoroutes on leur fait une place
réservée et puis on les alimentent à
l'électricité plutôt que au diesel ça
s'étudie ces choses là pour voir si
c'est rentable si c'est efficace si
c'est une bonne idée et pour le plaisir
et pour le fun je vous avais parlé du
fret ferroviaire mais je sais que c'est
très aventureux de se mettre sur ce
terrain là voilà je remercie beaucoup de
votre attention
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteure
merci beaucoup pour ses explications et
tout le propos liminaire qui est très
claire
on peut en tirer une première conclusion
nous on est sûr sur une mission
d'information au fait qu'est sur l'offre
automobile d'un point de vue je ne sais
plus l'ordre exact des termes
énergétiques fiscale industriel
écologique j'ajouterai sociale en termes
d'emploi
je voudrais peut-être aller directement
aux premiers propos de jean marc
jancovici sur le fait que les
perspectives économiques globales très
brillamment démontré font que les
instruments de politique publique à
privilégier c'est le levier fiscal et
levier réglementaire et en même temps
j'ai relevé une contradiction je voulais
creuser dans le propos quand vous avez
rapidement évoqué les bonus les primes à
la casse c'est à dire si on regarde
d'un point de vue aussi bien sanitaire
que écologique que l'intérêt industriel
la question première est celle du
renouvellement du parc qui se fait
depuis le zant plus lentement c'est à
dire que la durée de détention d'un
véhicule est aujourd'hui de plus en plus
longues et qu'on est une première
voiture de plus en plus tard si j'ai une
voiture neuve si je mets de côté la
question mais au moins majeur du marché
de l'occasion
donc peut-être à ce qu'on peut revenir
sur les instruments de politiques
publiques pour accélérer le
renouvellement du parc sachant que le
bonus et chaque année réduit pour qu'il
soit équilibré par le malus qui est qui
est perçu que les primes à la casse sont
coûteuses et qu elles ont toujours
provoquer des effets rebonds c'est à
dire qu'on a un effet on a un effet
soutien aux marchés automobiles dans un
premier temps mais dans un deuxième
temps les voitures qui ont été achetés
j'allais dire plus vite ne sont pas
achetées plus tard et donc on a des
effets des effets de report en fait
vingt deux reports enfin vous m'avez
compris donc ça c'est ma première
question la deuxième c'est sur les bases
des mesures fiscales et des mesures
réglementaires un des grands constat
qu'on fait dans nos travaux
c'est que jusqu'ici la réglementation
notamment européennes mais ça vaut aussi
pour les politiques publiques françaises
comme si on avait deux cerveaux c'est à
dire on a un cerveau climat et un autre
cerveau qualité de l'air donc
on a massivement encourager le diesel
avec un critère consommation et co2 sans
regarder assez vite même si elles ont
été regardées qu'il ya eu des
réglementations et un certain nombre de
progrès les questions de particules knox
etc et on a des réglementations
européennes avec d'un côté des
directives climat de l'autre côté des
directives quelle qualité de l'air ou
normes des véhicules sur les émissions
polluantes et sachant vous êtes tous les
deux d'éminents spécialistes c'est de
ces questions nous on se pose vraiment
le le problème de la proche des milk et
globale intégrant l'ensemble des
paramètres
je voudrais bien que vous développez
lier cette histoire de vignettes
c'est à dire ça veut dire quoi annuel
sur les émissions polluantes des
véhicules que ce soit des émissions co2
ou des ça dans votre esprit varane
brivio paix et ensuite je voudrais votre
point de vue sur la partie mobilité de
la ppe de la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie du projet qui est en cours
de consultation et de discussions voilà
pour l'instant
merci beaucoup y at il des collègues qui
souhaitent poser des questions non pour
ma part si vous le permettez je voudrais
juste ajouter une question qui peut
sembler un peu éloigné du du contexte ou
du sujet particulièrement monsieur jean
koffi 6 dans le scénario vous vous
développez de décroissance récession
plutôt annoncé et il a votre avis
accélérée par l'injection massive de
liquidités par les banques centrales
il est frais n'est vraiment oui ton
corps deuxième étape question sera t
elle encore plus grave que la précédente
non enfin plus plus grave du fait de
cette injection utilité mais en gros une
partie du pib qu'on achète en ce moment
c'est de l'inflation d'actifs qui est
financé par l'ailé des largesses de la
banque centrale et au moment où les
actifs se corriger à la baisse
donc si vous avez un krach immobilier a
craché pas quoi vous avez une correction
dans l'autre sens dont je suis un fichu
de connaître l'ampleur parce que je vois
pas avec quelle
type de modélisation de l'avenir je
serai capable de la calculer par contre
qu'elle n'arrive pas dans les quelques
années à venir voire même dans les
quelques mois à venir mais peu probable
mais on reste sur une appréciation du
contexte basé sur des liens de cause à
effet qui ne sont pas quantifiables une
deuxième petite question sur des
territoires où la taxe carbone a été ou
les marchés du carbone a été expérimenté
californie vos hypothèses ont t elles
étaient vérifiées d'accord non mais ça
alors j'ai il ya deux réponses qui vont
être très rapide mon avis sur la ppe est
nul puisque j'ai pas regardé et j'ai pas
d'avis et la taxe carbone n'est jamais
mise aujourd'hui à des niveaux qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir une influence dans
les questions de mobilité alain leurs
quelque chose qui est absolument
centrale à garder en tête 50 dollars le
baril
ces 100 euros la tonne de co2 ce qui
veut dire que si on attend gentiment que
le prix du pétrole remonte car malgré ce
que je dit tout à l'heure par ya un
moment où il finira par remonter ça veut
dire que vous dites aux producteurs est
bien mais sur les producteurs nous on
n'a pas eu le courage de taxer le
carbone chez nous donc on vous laisse
gentiment encaissé 100 euros la tonne de
sérieux quand le prix du pétrole remonte
voilà ce qu'on dit aux producteurs voilà
très exactement ce qu'on dit aux
producteurs dont on dit pas aux
conservateurs tu paye moins cher on dit
je cite tu vas pas payer des
fonctionnaires français qui va payer les
fonctionnaires russes vénézuélien
saoudiens qui sont ravis
après nous achète quelques sacs hermès
mais quand même ça le fait pas voilà
donc la taxe
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait avoir les
ordres de grandeur qu'il faut avoir en
tête aujourd'hui c'est que le niveau de
taxation du co2 qui déplace qui rend
légitime par exemple l'électrification
des véhicules
on parle de quelque chose qui se promène
entre 100 et 500 euros ça dépend du type
de véhicule machin des hypothèses que
vous faites sur le report modal j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que en fonction de
l'endroit où vous mettez le tramway et
le métro le bus etc
une paille trafic du trafic d'induction
si vous prenez 10 personnes aujourd'hui
qui empruntent le tramway de la petite
ceinture à paris il y en a au mieux un
qui vient de la voiture les autres avant
il prenait le métro il marchait à pied
ils prenaient le bus etc
donc vous pouvez pas dire j'ai dit
personne n'entre à moi j'ai évité dix
voitures
enfin je vais taquin peut-être 10 mai
nous les ingénieurs ont dit pas des
trucs comme ça donc l'oncle or si vous
dites je vais installer un tramway pour
éviter des voitures la vraie efficacité
du tramway c'est bien un passager sur 10
reporter de la voiture c'est comme ça
que vous devez faire le calcul si vous
réfléchissez à la bonne utilisation de
l'argent privé ou public
il n'y a pas de raison d'être plus
gaspilleur de l'argent privé donc la
question du coût à la tonne de co2
évitée qui est un truc qu'on va y
pullulent tous les jours chez nous se
promène dans une fourchette de quelques
de ces quelques centaines d'euros à la
tonne de co2 évitée dans les transports
quand vous passez par des voies purement
technologique ou donne un ordre de
grandeur
je ne connais pas un marché du co2 où on
est mis la tonne de carbone à 150 ou 200
euros
1 donc la réponse sur est-ce que ça
déplace en californie les transports la
réponse est un j'en sais rien parce que
j'ai pas été regardé mes deux je suis
prêt à parier une bouteille de champagne
avec vous que les faits et mon
perceptible la lola toujours dans les
questions rapides
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
subventionner la prime à la casse alors
qu'on n'a plus d'argent alors en fait on
a de l'argent quand on subventions il ya
des quelques cas de figure dans lesquels
on a quand même de l'argent quand on
subventionne le consommateur quelques
cas de figure c'est tous les cas de
figure où nonobstant ce que j'ai dit sur
le contexte macro économique
l'investissement permet de baisser les
importations de combustibles fossiles a
service constant
deux exemples évidents l'isolation des
logements chauffés au gaz et au fioul et
ceux là qui sont chauffés à
l'électricité ça change pas la balance
commerciale et la baisse de la
consommation des véhicules à déplacement
constant ça ces deux mesures là elles
sont croissantes east au sens où vous
éviter des importations a service
constant
donc tout ce que vous ne payez pas à
l'étranger vous le rapatrie vous êtes
capable de le dépenser en service
domestique qui emploie du monde donc
c'est croissanciste entre guillemets a
servi constants alors faisons un rapide
calcul les importations de pétrole a en
france avant que le pétrole se casse la
gueule c'était de l'ordre de 80 à 90
milliards d'euros par an maintenant on
va dire que c'est 50
non mais pardon dollars 80 90 milliard
de dollars donc c'était 50 voilà mais
dont 50 milliards d'euros en ordre de
grandeur ça va être moins mais ça va
être plus peu importe 50 milliards
d'euros ça veut dire que si vous êtes
capable d'éviter durablement la moitié
de cette consommation
disons 25 si vous investissez dans
quelque chose dont la nuitée et de deux
pour cent de votre investissement
initial
vous avez le droit de multiplier 25 x 56
les taux sont nulles pour obtenir le
montant de l'investissement que vous
pouvez consentir sans effets macro
économique évident ni dans un sens ni
dans l'autre
ça fait quand même un paquet d'argent il
ya 30 millions de véhicules qui
circulent en france
si vous dites que chaque véhicule vos
vingt mille euros vous avez 600
milliards d'actifs circulants bas je
vous ai dit 30 x 25 vous êtes à 750
enfin briller donc il ya moyen de
s'arranger mais c'est le seul cas de
figure dans lequel vous pouvez le faire
parce que vous re circuler une
externalité positif qui est des
émissions des réservations ont évité si
vous subventionnez un truc qui n'a pas
d'effet sur les importations
là c'est clair que vous avez perdu votre
argent et vous leur maître vous le
retrouverez pas pour faire autre chose
si vous évitez de prendre un exemple
après très concret je sais pas si c'est
encore temps de faire passer ça dans une
loi de finances mais qui est la question
du biogaz propositions très précises à
faire aussi
donc si donc si une partie de ces de cet
argent qu'il faudrait mettre dans une
prime à la casse et on peut le trouver
dans les émissions enfin dans les
importations éviter mais quelque chose
qu'il faut absolument savoir est que m'a
appris le grand maître orfeuil c'est que
les gens ont une logique budgétaire
quand il s'agit des transports et donc
on les limites de ce qu'a évoqué alain
qui sont que biologiquement vous n'allez
pas faire trente mille kilomètres par an
juste pour plaisir simplement parce que
l'essence coûte moins cher si vous avez
du transport qui devient économiquement
plus accessible les gens vont consommer
plus parce que les gens ont une logique
budgétaire alors ce que disait orfeuil
c'est un peu moins vrai maintenant mais
ce que disait orfeuil à 10 ou 15 ans il
disait c'est très simple en ile de
france les gens qui ont les moyens
d'avoir une voiture ou une voiture et
les gens qui n'ont pas de voiture c'est
des gens qui ont pas les moyens d'avoir
une voiture y compris le cadre qui
pourrait l'acheter mais cas pas les
moyens de la gare et quand il va la
défense donc vous retrouver dans les
transports en commun les gens qui
ils n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter une
voiture pas de places de parking à
destination et enfin voilà c'est cela
que vous allez retrouver pour
l'essentiel dans les transports en
commun disait orfeuil c'est un peu moins
vrai maintenant mais il ya quelque chose
de vrai là dedans
ce qui veut dire que si vous passez les
voitures à 2 litres au cent alors
qu'elle était à 6 litres
eh bien il faut tripler prix de
l'essence c'est exactement ça qu'il faut
faire
alors vous pouvez tripler le prix de
l'essence ou bien vous pouvez passer par
une vignette alors une vignette c'est
quoi c'est une taxe annuelle à la
détention qui est gradué de telle sorte
que vous pourrez continuer dans ce
monde-là avoir une voiture qui consomme
10 litres par an juste ça va vous coûter
ou à la moitié du prix de la voiture
tous les ans si vous avez envie de payer
très cher ami payer donc c'est ça l'idée
et la fameuse vignette qu'on a supprimé
en 2000 la toute petite différence c'est
que là dit niet à l'époque était
fonction que de la puissance en fait la
consommation et l était pas fonction
d'externalités donc quand je dis vinet
de co2 sévigné fonction des émissions de
co2 et le gros intérêt du système c'est
que l'inconvénient du bonus malus un ca
ses terres c'est qu'on paye qu'une fois
et après moult à tort comme votre sujet
si le renouvellement du parc
il faut que la peine je sais qu'il faut
préfère d'écologie punitive mais il la
peine se rappelle à vous chaque année et
donc la fin de l'histoire vous commencez
à la trouvais ça un peu désagréable ça
vous un site assez fortement
à changer s'il ya une offre alternative
après le lait le point de jean-marc je
le redis avec mes terres mais je tire
pas sa parole c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet robot c'est à dire que le
problème de voiture basse consommation
si c'est pas compensé par une taxe
carbone c'est que l'essence coûte pas
cher vous avez tendance à en consommer
plus ces belles que ça elle peut être
par ailleurs différenciée selon les
départements
aujourd'hui ce qu'on évoque c'est un
principe général
donc là on n'est pas arrivé avec la
règle à calcul complète
oui alors là dessus on avait un avis
très tranché dont je n'ai pas dévié
depuis le club pas s'il vous plaît qui
est que le prix de l'énergie doit être
unique pour tous et lisible et la
réglementation des voitures unique pour
tous et lisible et c'est par des mesures
distinctes qu'il faut éventuellement
redistribués par ailleurs dont vous ne
pouvez dire éventuellement l'état dans
sa grande générosité
alou à toute personne habitant dans un
département enfin maintenant il rappelé
département donc dans une zone à créer
ça va être un sujet de débats
intéressants dont la densité de
peuplement est inférieure à z habitants
par hectare une prime de temps pour aide
à la mobilité
voilà ça on peut très bien faire ce
genre de choses la dernière des choses à
faire c'est de moduler à la tête de pipe
la peine dont parlait alain alors je
suis d'accord avec lui il faut surtout
pas parler d'écologie punitive mais le
l'incitation à ne pas faire il faut pas
qu'elle devienne illisible et parce que
sinon ici vous connaissez les
marchandages de cette maison parker et
moi et moi et moi et les buralistes ils
soient déjà donc tu apprennes quand même
collé cette rue de la fabrique ou non
mais voilà donc on n'en sort plus
dernier point sur le biogaz
je disais tout à l'heure il faut en
priorité si on s'intéresse à cette
question allez c'est une des règles
cardinales à mon avis allait aux
investissements qui demande le moins de
capitaux par unité de résultats espérés
donc je veux supprimer un litre de
diesel je me suis pris mais un litre
d'essence je veux supprimer une tonne de
co2 je veux supprimer un kilo de
particules fines dans l'univers
économique qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
il faut commencer par les mesures qui
ont le plus faible capex par unité
éviter
ça fait la sphère de la collectivité ça
ne fait évidemment pas les affaires des
gens qui vendent les équipements parce
que il préfère que vous alliez au plus
fort taux de capex par unité éviter et
alors pour ça ça veut dire que dans le
domaine du biogaz lusage qu'il faut
favoriser en premier c'est la
substitution aux carburants pétroliers
alors qu'aujourd'hui on substitue en
favorisant premier la génération
électrique
on vient encore de lui donner un coup de
pouce les menteurs oui en supprimant
l'obligation sur la valorisation de la
chaleur
oui absolument et oui absolument on est
d'accord que c'est stupide c'est pas moi
qui l'ait fallait donc mais il faut
absolument favoriser en premier
l'utilisation en substitution des
carburants bah vous êtes bien placé pour
savoir pourquoi est ce que dans ce pays
c'est la substitution de l'électricité
et qu'il y ait le plus poussé par une
fraction des gens qui ont accès aux
médias donc le meilleur en attendant si
on s'intéresse à la question des
transports routiers
c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire c'est et
du pétrole plus largement s'est
substitué les usages carburants et là il
ya notamment quelque chose à mon avis
assez intéressant à faire alors qui
concerne pas les grandes agglomérations
mais qui concerne tous les départements
ruraux et les petites villes qui est de
regarder partout où on peut valoriser
facilement le gaz issu des déchets
agricoles dans des dessertes régionales
ou locales de bus cars scolaires
desserte des moyennes villes et c est
donc là il ya un vrai sujet alain on a
parlé vers lequel il faudrait
fiscalement fléché la valorisation du
biogaz rapidement parce que quand vous
regardez les externalités évité par le
biogaz c'est clairement dans l'est dans
le carburant éviter que c'est le plus
intéressant à la fois en termes
d'importations et en termes soit dit en
passant d'emplois induits juste un tout
petit point de commentaires très
technique dans la définition de la
contribution carbone présente
actuellement il n'y a pas de distinction
entre le co2 d'origine
biogénie qui le co2 d'origine fossile
est ce qui de notre point de vue est
vraiment que c'était modifier tout à
fait récemment mais dans la première
construction ça l'était pas tenez je
parle sous le contrôle du président du
groupe d'étude sur ces sujets on à eddy
auditionné grt gaz etc
la semaine dernière qui nous parlaient
eux de la garantie d'origine se réglait
le problème ça veut dire qu'ils ont
trouvé une manière de contourner
l'obstacle en tous les cas je rebondis
et jamais je pense que venir jean marc
il est important dans une logique
générale digne de réduction d'émission
de particules fines dans les
centres-villes de s'occuper de ces
choses à parce que d'un point de vue
industriel le développement du bus au
gaz ou de camions au gaz il va être il
est tiré par par quelque chose et 1d il
ya une liaison entre la capacité de
production de ces fameux biogaz et leur
usage dans le transport et l'usagé
centrale par rapport à votre question
donc c'est peut-être un peu compliqué
c'était un jeu de billard demande mais
ça me paraît sur la table vraiment et
puisqu'on alain dudon dernier point qui
est la question industrielle ce que vous
en avez parlé sur le déploiement de ce
genre de véhicule alors commençons par
les bus il ya des compétences en france
iveco à une usine de moteurs qui fait
des moteurs gaz et là on va dire que les
barrières à l'entrée sur les gros
moteurs sont telles que la
délocalisation de ce genre d' usine
c'est quand même pas un truc qui va si
vite que ça donc là on peut y aller
assez franco à mon avis assez vite
les acteurs présents en france ils
sauront en tirer parti sur les voitures
c'est une toute autre histoire parce que
sur les voitures aujourd'hui il faut
faire une nouvelle chaîne dédiée à la
production de véhicules à deux litres au
cent si on veut la lancée et là sans
trahir de secrets le seuil de
rentabilité et d'un investissement de
cette nature ces quelques centaines de
milliers de véhicules par an or le
marché automobile français aujourd'hui
est de 2 millions mais en baisse puisque
comme vous l'avez très justement dit en
univers économiquement contraint la
durée de détention des objets s'accroît
c'est vrai pour tous
et ça va notamment être vrai pour les
voitures dans l'univers que j'ai décrit
qui est peut-être pas très rose mais
enfin que j'ai décrit la tendance
naturelle des gens va être de conserver
l'existant de plus en plus longtemps et
ce que vous constatez aujourd'hui c'est
à bas bruit ce qui va s'amplifier plus
tard je le redis 1 depuis 2007 le monde
a changé et être en train de changer et
donc effectivement c'est plus en plus
les vieux qui achètent des voitures de
plus on a neuf de plus en plus vieux et
c'est le si vous voulez qu'un acteur
peut jouer pour ne pas le nommer puisque
c'est lui qui a pris position de la
manière la plus offensive sur la
question du véhicule trèbes le manceau
matters investissent les quelques
milliards d'euros qui sont nécessaires
dans une usine fabrique ce genre de truc
il n'a pas le faire juste pour nos beaux
yeux
il va le faire s'il a la garantie que le
retour sur investissement arrivera c'est
à dire que le marché est protégée sur
une durée suffisamment longue et pour un
volume suffisamment important pour que
ça arrive protéger un marché et porte le
très vilain non de protectionnisme je
pense pour ma part la première fois que
je les écris c'était en 2002 sur les
infrastructures lourdes la libre
concurrence est une ânerie sans nom ça
conduit à perdre du capital et pas à
améliorer le sort commun et donc ce
qu'il faut sur les domaines qui
demandent des investissements très
lourds c'est un oligopole bien régulé
dit autrement on encadre la rente de
l'acteur privé à des niveaux qui sont
telles que socialement ça reste
acceptable
ça peut être un monopole ou un oligopole
ça dépend des ça dépend des secteurs
donc qu'il s'agisse des transports de
l'industrie lourde de la fabrication
très capitalistique des moyens de
transport je deviens très capitalistique
qui voulaient faire des vélos c'est pas
le même problème mais très
capitalistique des moyens de transport
dans les trains et les voitures et
encore plus les avions de l'électricité
etc
l'idée que la libre concurrence prépare
un album meilleur pour le consommateur
et le citoyen français est
malheureusement une vue de l'esprit
là on a un petit sujet dans la
construction européenne mais on est déjà
en train de le sentir
les anglais qui étaient les plus
libéraux du lot sont en train de faire
dans leur électricité à eux
l'exact inverse de ce qu'ils ont
distillé à la commission pendant 20 ans
ils sont en train de faire dans leur
transport à eux du jacobinisme bien
senti j'ai pas si vous savez mais le
grand londres
johnson a dit c'est moi le chef pour
tous et ça marche le mieux en cours de
tous donc l'intermodalité il n'y a pas
de problème il sait quand arrivent les
bus et quand partent les trains etc et
donc du coup les connexions se font les
infrastructures sont après c'est moi le
chef c'est pas vraiment ce que vous avez
appris des anglais dans leurs traditions
libérales etc
deux des dernières décennies donc il ya
un moment où il faut savoir être
intelligemment régulateur je ne dis pas
que que l'état s'occupe du sort de
chacun sait pas du tout ce que je suis
en train de dire il ya des domaines dans
lesquels il faut accepter l'idée que la
concurrence libre et non faussée etc
c'est pas le bonheur du peuple à long
terme et qu'il faut être un peu plus un
peu plus agile que ça là aussi et pas
dogmatique et donc la question de la
substitution rapide des moyens de
transport compte tenu des montants en
jeu les du tout à l'heure le parc
français c'est 600 milliards d'euros les
infrastructures de transport en france
est de l'ordre du millier de milliard
c'est absolument évident que ce n'est
pas en disant je fais trois règles de
marché et que le meilleur gagne que en
univers économique contraint de on va
profondément par la main invisible à
quelque chose qui sera extrêmement
pertinents donc une fois que j'ai fait
cette grande diatribe sur la partie
fabrication des véhicules à deux litres
je pense que ça va de pair avec le fait
qu'il faut commencer à étudier de très
près les possibilités d'exception à la
règle de libre concurrence qui doivent
être possibles puisque pour la pac on en
a fait un certain nombre
donc je pense que sans modifier les
traités il doit y avoir quelque chose de
possible sur la gestion des exceptions
et en particulier qu'à partir de
maintenant on fasse rentrer dans les
têtes l'idée que la sauvegarde du
vaisseau spatial qui s'appelle la terre
et la baisse de la dépendance délétère
de l'europe pour combustible importé
peut justifier des exceptions à la règle
commune applicables aux producteurs de
carottes de chevalet 2
chaises et de chaussures et tant que
vous n'aurez pas réglé ce problème
la question de la politique industrielle
intégrée avec la politique
environnementale
vous n'arriverez pas à la règle et du
noël qu'il faut absolument franchir dont
on peut bricoler je dis pas qu'on peut
absolument rien faire
puissiez trouver les interstices etc
mais pour faire en grand un truc qui
sont vraiment devenues nécessaires il
faut absolument s'attaquer de front à ce
problème qui est qu'aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas faire de politique intégrée
industrie slash environnement dans le
contexte actuel dont vous pouvez faire
une bonne politique environnementale ça
renvoie à ce qui était dit tout à
l'heure
faire en même temps la bonne politique
industrielle qui va avec on n'est pas
équipé pour thil chers collègues des
questions complémentaires il est
peut-être la question qui se pose est
aussi du calendrier possible pour une
reconversion industrielle
compte tenu des indications que vous
venez de donner avez vous une idée d'un
timing qui seraient susceptibles d'être
acceptable pour nous aussi vite que
possible mais je crois qu'elle 1 il a un
avis personnel sur les fenêtres
politique pour commencer à faire des
choses en grand
est-ce qu'on peut raisonner sur le
calendrier industriel indépendamment du
calendrier politique je crois pas je ne
parle pas en quoi je crois qu'on est il
ya des horizons très long qui sont les
horizons du bâtiment et du logement une
maison c'est s'entendent durée de vie le
parc de véhicules ça doit être invité
les ornements de 12 13 ans ouais même je
crois et donc c'est par rapport à ça
qu'il faut faire faire les raisonnements
politiques puisque les icônes les
constructeurs et les industries les
raisonne par rapport à ses horizons on
l'a donc on est forcément sur cd pas de
temps qui sont fonction de ces ceux de
ces délais là c'est pas précis mais je
vois pas comment on peut être beaucoup
plus précis que ça moi l'impression que
j'ai par ailleurs et plus globalement
c'est que ce qui est attendu des
industriels heures en matière de normes
de règles et de fiscalité c'est de la
visibilité et de la stratégie
on a vu que c'est une évidence absolue
mais face à rethel folle à redire donc
si on a un regret en disant notre
cerveau gauche
et m et knox et notre cerveau droit et
co2 et on n'a pas bien coller les deux
cerveaux ensemble et donc du coup on se
trouvait des trop de nox et trop de co2
et de n2o et pas assez de pardon et paix
mais et du co2 on est plutôt content que
ça baisse il faut il faut que le signal
des dix quinze vingt prochaines années
soit c'est ça qu'on joue sur ces deux
tableaux là et entre temps comme on l'a
dit je pense tout le long de cette de
cette réunion avec vous entre temps il
est tellement progrès technologiques
qu'on est devant des perspectives qui
sont jouables c'était le fameux gagnant
gagnant en faire je gagne sur pm épine
boxe et je gagne sur co2 c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut envisager aujourd'hui
je pense qu'aussi en avait posé ce sujet
là en 2007 on en rit quelques ennuis
parce que les industries vous auriez
vous êtes fous là il peut pas nous dire
ça vraiment pas donc il faut à mon avis
si je raisonne en calendrier le ce qui
me paraît essentielle c'est c'est la
tendance des crédible
bon qui fera qu'il sera créé d'ici à
vous de le voir mais sur des horizons de
10 à 20 ans et ensuite des chances qui
permettent de franchir des étapes année
après année parce que la logique
industrielle est comme ça c'est
finalement je crois que notre collègue
une question puisqu'elle merci c'est
l'aude aux oligopoles ou au monopole qui
fait suggérer la question donc pour les
constituer
quels sont les chemins à prendre et
peut-être en termes d'organisation du
système financier et de préconisations
donc des modes de financement assez
oligopole ya pas besoin d constitué pays
existent quand vous regardez la
construction de voitures en france et un
oligopole il est guidé la enfin je veux
dire vous avez deux groupes français
quelques groupes étrangers qui ont des
usines en france moi je veux dire vous
avez un nombre d'acteurs quand vous
discutez avec les acteurs du monde
automobile en france vous avez dix
personnes dans la salle qu'il existe
déjà
quand vous regardez les gestionnaires
d'infrastructures existe déjà
vous avez un gestionnaire ou le réseau
ferré et vous avez trois gestionnaires
pour les autoroutes concédées
vous avez un gestionnaire délégué par
petits morceaux pour les routes
anciennement dite nationale je suis pas
en train de dire il faut du monopole ou
l'oligopole partout je le redis j'ai
aucune envie que ce soit un
fonctionnaire qui s'occupe de fabriquer
mes chaussures
par contre je pense que quand on est
dans un monde dans lequel la barrière à
l'entrée est monstrueusement
capitalistique la de vouloir à toute
force faire rentrer de la concurrence et
air et un ccarq son temps et perd son
argent voilà c'est juste ça que je suis
en train de dire donc le vous n'allez
pas faire trois eurotunnel au motif qu'
il faut de la concurrence sur le trafic
transmanche d'accord moi un moment où
vous dites j'en fais un jeu réguler
voilà et il n'ya pas besoin d'aller les
chercher ailleurs l'iso que là où ils
sont vous les avez déjà en face de vous
après ce qu'il faut là je vais être un
peu taquin s'est retrouvé au sein de la
fonction publique et du monde politique
une capacité à discuter sur les mêmes
horizons de temps que ce dont a parlé à
l'impasse que je vais être un tout petit
peu provocant par ce qui est peu par
rapport à ce qu'il a dit vous trouvez
encore m
des choses hallucinantes même dans des
sociétés cotées avec des comptes
trimestriels et ça vous trouvez encore
de temps en temps en cherchant bien en
grattant bien là comme le sel dans la
mousse vous arrivez à trouver un type
qui s'occupe de discuter à 20 ans et
revient de temps en temps là dessus il
va voir le monde politique monde
politique va vous dire je te garantis un
cadre stable sur 20 ans ils le croient
aujourd'hui c'est le sujet du document
raconte n'importe quoi à l'approché
d'élections tu vas dire exactement
l'inversé tu es jeux à faire un peu de
fact checking vous savez je vais prendre
les 60 propositions de la dernière
élection puis je la regardais ce
qu'elles sont devenues des cas aucune
confiance donc le dialogue
je suis pas en train de défendre
l'entreprise prix est juste en train de
vous dire la situation telle qu'elle est
dont vous avez un vrai sujet aujourd'hui
c'est que l'état retrouve une position
d'acteur crédible et j'insiste sur le
crédible dans sa capacité à faire des
cadres de moyen et de long terme qui
crée une confiance partagée avec les
acteurs qu'il a en face de lui et je
suis au regret de dire qu'aujourd'hui ça
n'existe pas ça n'existe pas pour plein
de raisons donc on va pas épiloguer mais
c'est un sujet majeur à mon avis de
préoccupation pour le monde politique
c'est vraiment un sujet de préoccupation
majeur ça doit être vu comme un sujet de
préoccupation majeur pour le monde
politique
merci beaucoup
madame la porte une dernière question il
est champion j'en avais une dernière bon
on peut par ailleurs un jour une
approche
comment dire non sur le caractère
prévisible est planifiée de la
réglementation qui est évident c'est le
problème qui a actuellement sur les sur
les nouvelles normes européennes qui
sont pas encore décidées début 2015 et
qui sont censé s'appliquer en 2017
donc on voit ça en long en large et en
travers dans le travail qu'on est en
train de faire non ma question c'est est
sûre le vous avez dit à un moment donné
je ne sais plus lequel tu vaux de vous
deux faut pas mettre d'argent public
considérable sur des choix
technologiques
c'est alain qualifiant c'est alain si on
veut pouvoir faire ce qui est évoqué sur
la question du biogaz par exemple si on
veut développer aujourd'hui massivement
le transport de marchandises avec des
camions fonctionnant au gaz ou au biogaz
on a un problème d'infrastructures
si on veut faire un environnement de
développement possible pour le véhicule
électrique on a un sujet
d'infrastructures donc même si on
reformule une position de l'état qui
serait celle de la neutralité
technologique avec des critères
réglementaires ou fiscaux claire basée
sur des critères objectifs co2
particules nox et c'est qu'ils soient
beaucoup plus simple beaucoup plus
claire et j'allais dire ensuite aux
acteurs économiques de se débrouiller
pour pour remplir les cases et atteindre
les objectifs et respecter les règles
l'état doit quand même faire des choix
par rapport à ses infrastructures
voilà donc c'est sur cette contradiction
je voulais pointé alors je vais
peut-être dont je veux pas faire parler
les présents dont 15 en dira ce qu'il a
voulu dire exactement par les choix moi
je comprends comme à un moment où le jeu
reste ouvert avec voilà avec avec avec
des technologies qui sont concurrentes
pour atteindre un résultat identique
il faut pas présenter un résultat un
moment où on n'a pas les cartes en main
pour savoir ce qui va sortir
moi j'ai su ce que j'ai compris un oui
moi ce que je voulais dire très
précisément c'est que mettre beaucoup
d'argent public sur la voiture
électrique il ya un moment où on envoie
en vingt mille par an ça me parait
aventureux parce qu'on ne sait pas
si cette technologie à l'emporter sur
nos véhicules hybrides rechargeables
c'est ça que je dis j'ai peur voilà où
ou si c'est pas la ville à la
motorisation badauds les 300 qui a gagné
la partie donc c'est ça que j'ai dit
mais je n'ai pas dit qu'il fallait pas
du tout un vestiaire en infrastructures
et j'ai dit ici sur le le bus au gaz
d'une part et sur l'électrique envie
d'autre part et les choses à faire donc
la nuance est dans le la quantité
d'argent et dans le déploiement coup
fait c'est à dire installer un chef
caricature parce que je sais bien que
c'est pas du tout votre invention mais
installer des bornes de recharge
électrique dans toute la france en se
disant les voitures électriques et ils
vont avoir besoin d'une borne de
recharge régulière pour se recharger
comme ils en ont pour se recharger sans
ça me paraît aujourd'hui très prématuré
c'est ça mon point et si j'ai insisté
sur les flottes et sur le bus c'est que
c'est précisément à mon avis des modems
des bannières d'optimiser la dépense
puisque si on met sur la pose de buses
d'acteurs comme les ratés
les buts lyonnais là quand il s'appelle
non il le métro lyonnais fatou
l'opérateur lyonnais oui eh ben on aura
besoin d'eux on a un acteur on a un
système de capes qui est limitée et dont
on voit bien le contou bon c'est ça mon
coin je vais faire une toute petite
incidente et je veux revenir à la
politique sur un point important
une des choses que j'ai apprises après
le grand plaidoyer qu'on a sorti sur la
taxe carbone c'est qu'une solution
rationnelle à un problème rationnel ne
fait pas un truc qui enthousiasme les
gens donc ça veut dire que c'est
nécessaire mais pas suffisant et la
raison pour laquelle on aime tant les
arbitrages technologique c'est que
l'arbitrage technologie qui nomme projet
lydie c'est là que les gens vont bosser
c'est là que je vais dire qu'il ya des
objets a montré c'est là que je vais
voir couper déroulement c'est là que etc
il y en a besoin de ça donc sans me
mettre du tout en porte à faux par
rapport à ce que vient de dire alain il
ya un équilibre perpétuel à trouver
entre je fais quand même des choses
parce que je dois incarner l'action dans
les trucs qui sont un peu contré je ne
peux pas me contenter même si elles sont
indispensables de mesures qui sont le
cadre fiscal réglementaire et cetera qui
permet aux choses de naître parce que le
cadre fiscal et réglementaire c'est
d'abord la règle du jeu contraignante et
ensuite le tout sympathique
chronologiquement c'est dans cet ordre
que les choses se font et
particulièrement en ce moment où on a
besoin de messages d'espoir on préfère
que ça se fasse dans l'autre sens
d'abord alors du sympathique et ensuite
on voudra bien avoir un peu de
réglementaire ses skis avec des
expressions un peu caricatural a été
illustré par l'écologie punitive et
autres trucs de ce genre là à droite
comme à gauche je suis pas en train de
distribuer bons et mauvais points chacun
avec sa formule l'a dit donc le donc à
un moment on est obligés de faire ses
choix à cause à cause de ça parce qu'on
n'a pas le temps de dire aux gens on ne
peut pas dire aux gens je fais juste
l'interdiction je vous assure attendais
un peu ils à sortir des trucs rigolos
vous êtes obligé l'homme et les choses
par contre la bonne nouvelle c'est que
quand on fait quelques calculs simples
hélas trop souvent absents en préalable
de la décision publique or les calculs
simples s'appelle général eric de trois
parfois compliqué eh bien on arrive
assez vite
à faire la part des choses entre les
trucs qui sont mort nés les trucs qui
ont du potentiel mais qui sont pas
encore là et les trucs qui sont prêts à
être déployés et en particulier une
règle cardinale qui serait de calcul est
systématiquement les investissements au
litre de pétrole éviter ou à la tonne de
co2 évitée permettrait de faire un
premier tri dans les investissements
très robuste vraiment très robuste parce
que ça ça vous dit tout de suite si vous
allez vous essouffler avant d'avoir
réglé un centième du problème ou si vous
allez déployé quelque chose qui va
prendre une place significative dans
l'éventail des solutions et par ailleurs
on aime bien en france réseau n'est tout
blanc ou noir donc alain d'une manière
moi je veux redire d'une autre manière
c'est pas voitures électriques par
voiture électrique il y aura des
voitures électriques la bonne question
c'est de savoir s'il y en aura cinquante
mille ou 10 millions ou n'importe quoi
entre les deux voilà il ya des cas de
figure dans lesquelles la voiture
électrique a toute sa pertinence des cas
de figure dans la dernière c'est dans
lesquelles c'est là derrière des
conneries à faire enfin voilà il n'ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de
les français bien les vérités
universelles mais en fait ce qu'il faut
c'est avoir la possibilité de nommer
précisément les choses sur l'action mais
par contre d'avoir des règles de gestion
qui permettent de savoir ce qu'on fait
qu'ils aient elles sont technologie
notre hall justement qui sont qui
s'applique quel que soit le choix qu'on
fait et qui permettent de comparer les
éventualités les unes avec les autres
à la fois en termes de potentiel et de
et de groupe et on en manque cruellement
dans la gestion énergétique soit dit en
passant dans la manière dont on fait les
choix